I hate lies I just don't like them tell
me the truth and then tell me why I
should still support you don't lie to me
and one of the lies that Joe Biden has
told is that he was arrested when
visiting South Africa in the 1970s the
story Biden has been telling is that he
was in South Africa during the apartheid
times and was arrested and for example
Biden said in South Carolina last month
quote this day thirty years ago Nelson
Mandela walked out of prison and entered
into discussions about apartheid I had
the great honour of meeting him I had
the great honor of being arrested with
our UN Ambassador on the streets of
Soweto trying to get to see him on
Robben Island now on February 16th Joe
Biden said he got arrested trying to see
Nelson Mandela in prison and on February
18th he said the same thing again about
a story about how he got his wife Jill
to marry him it turns out all three of
those instances of claiming he was
arrested were untrue
the New York Times researched it they
found no evidence that Joe Biden was
arrested in South Africa former UN
Ambassador who was on the trip back in
the 70s that try out that Biden refers
to says I have no recollection or
knowledge of Joe Biden getting arrested
so Joe Biden was confronted about this
and the casual nature with which he just
brushes off that he lied multiple times
about being arrested admits he wasn't
telling the truth and then just moves on
is really horrible let's take a look at
the video I do want to ask you about one
thing that you've said repeatedly on the
trail I think it's three times now you
said that during a visit to South Africa
to visit Nelson Mandela which I know was
a very memorable visit for you that you
were arrested when you were there your
campaign has come out since and said no
no you were separated from other people
at the airport but you didn't say
arrests three times what why well what I
meant to say was I got off that look I
strongly strongly strongly opposed to
tarp apartheid I was one of the leaders
I mean you doubt it go on Joe Biden calm
and look at the exchange between George
Shultz and me in the Foreign Relations
Committee and here's the deal I was in
with a black delegation the CDC the the
the Congressional Black Caucus they had
me get off a plane the copper Conners
the short pants and their guns let me
offer led me off first and move me in a
direction totally differently turn
around and everybody all the entire
black delegation was gone another way I
said I'm not going to go in that door
that says wait only I'm going with them
I said you're not you can't move you
can't go with them and they and they
kept me there until finally I decided
they were clear I wasn't going to move
and so what they finally did they said
okay they're not gonna make the
congressional delegation go through the
black door they're not gonna make me go
through the white door they went took us
out my memory serves me through a
baggage claim area up to a restaurant
and they cleared out a restaurant I felt
strongly about apartheid one of the
reasons we were there and after long
after this when Nelson Mandela was freed
and came to the United States he came to
my office it was one of the most
incredible men ever met he sat down
office thanked me thanked me for trying
to all the work I did on apartheid I
truly don't get this I don't you lied
about being arrested no no no I was
against apartheid but we're not arguing
about that Joe we're arguing about the
arrest claims and there are two
possibilities and both are both are
conceivable either Biden's memory is
gone which is a concern that's been
raised many many times or Biden was
deliberately lying when he claimed to be
arrested in South Africa thinking and
maybe it won't be fact-check and that's
also very very bad is it believable by
the way that someone might have a sort
of hazy recollection of whether or not
they were arrested or merely separated
from the group I was arrested once I've
told the story I was at a party when I
was 20 and I was holding half a beer
which I had not yet even taken a sip of
I was five months shy of my 21st
birthday police entered the the party
because of a noise complaint I happened
to be by the door holding a beer and I
was arrested it was traumatic I've been
at a ton of other parties I've sometimes
been separated from my friends I've
traveled all over the world and been in
all sorts of situations there is no
doubt whatsoever in my mind I was never
arrested at any of those things
I was only arrested in July of 2004
that's the only time I was arrested it
is not hazy being arrested is traumatic
you remember it now if Biden were
someone like for example Jane Fonda who
gets herself arrested for protesting
multiple
time's okay maybe you forget that I get
arrested at the Austin Texas event or
the San Antonio event or something like
that that is not this situation so I
don't know I would find it it would be
refreshing to me for Joe Biden just to
apologize for telling a story that
wasn't true and by the way for telling
it at least three times instead of what
I meant when I said I got arrested is
that I was separated from my group and I
was against apartheid
during that time in South Africa it's
not good it's not good folks will follow
up on this on our Instagram account at
David Pakman show follow me on Instagram
at David Pakman we will take a very
brief break and be right back I want to
give a quick shout-out to one of our
sponsors VIN Charo watches they're
giving my audience 15% off your entire
order when you go to david pakman.com
slash watch maybe you don't usually wear
a watch and you've been thinking about
looking for one to elevate your look or
you've been thinking about replacing the
one you have check out VIN Charo it's an
American company all of their watches
are built in small batches from high-end
materials they look amazing and they
look like something you'd spend a lot of
money on but ever even Cheryl watch
ranges from a hundred and fifty to three
hundred dollars I went on their website
and picked out the Kyros in white and
silver really loved the look the
combination of the white face and the
beige band really loved this one they
also sent me the Kairos limited release
gold reserve set totally different style
this one would make a fantastic gift for
a couple people I can think of in my
family any time you see me wearing a
watch on the show I'm wearing a Ventura
watch go through their collection I know
you'll find something you like and
you'll get 15% off when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch